Jason is with us in Oklahoma hi Jason
welcome to show how can I help
hey Dave thank you for having me sure
what's up I'm having a hard time
wrapping my mind around the value of
money in the stock market especially in
today's environment and so it just seems
like the price of the price of a lot of
stocks is completely irrelevant to the
company's earnings I event so my
question is if my money is more
effective in real estate than it is in
the stock market since if I buy a rental
property for example it actually
generates cash whereas the only value
that you get from a from a stock is
whenever you you sell it and if somebody
wants that particular certificate of
stock well or if you buy a dividend
paying stock which I don't buy single
stars anyway but we can discuss the
philosophy or the concepts behind it
generally speaking generally speaking
you would make a lot if you do a good
job with it you would make a lot more
rate of return on real estate but it
involves more hassle more of your time
even if you hire management company or
whatever you've still got more time than
just buying a mutual fund and throwing
it in the drawer and forget it okay and
you get the statements on your email you
know once a quarter once a month or
whatever you have zero hassle factor
buying a mutual fund or buying stocks
unless you're gonna try to buy and sell
them which I would never recommend but a
buy and hold strategy on real estate
while it generates cash flow
it should outperform stocks but it has
more hassle it outperforms mainly
because it's an imperfect market in
terms of that's an economic term you may
be familiar with a perfect market is one
where all buyers and sellers have
exactly the same information in the
exact same access to buy and so the
stock market is closer to a perfect
market than real estate real
say each item is unique its unique to a
certain area and all buyers and sellers
never have even close to the same amount
of information or belief about a piece
of real estate and so real estate gives
you a lot more opportunity to get a
bargain in other words and and if you're
willing to invest the time you should
make more on it real estate creates
three types of return one is as you said
increase in value and cash flow is 2
which is the rental income on it and 3
is you get to depreciate it so you
actually get a tax break that covers a
portion or all of your rent that comes
in and that actually has a cash value to
it so when you put those three together
that's called an internal rate of return
have you ever heard that yes ok so an
IRR on a piece of a piece of real estate
that is under under a million dollars a
piece a small apartment or small you
know a basic home a small office or
something like that your your IR RS
ought to be north of 15 percent mine are
almost everything I own that's income
producing and your cash on cash in most
cases with a typical piece of real
investment property would be 8 to 12
percent somewhere in there your cash on
cash alone would be that now again on
stocks you got two possible places of
return one is the increase in value and
two is the and twos possible dividend
payouts which are profits shared with
the owners of the company and when your
stockholder you're an owner of the
company so you could get dividend payout
stocks and you'd have a you'd have a
cash flow with that kind of a thing and
you'd have the increases in value so in
both markets though people make the
statements that you were making that
it's artificially high or it's
ridiculous or there's a bubble or
there's no way that that supports that
when in reality there's a few times that
that's the case we had a tech bubble in
1999 the the.com rage where people were
buying stocks on companies that have
never made a profit so that was
ridiculous obviously and they shot
through the roof most of those didn't
survive a few name brands that are
household names did survive like for
instance Amazon and so but but by and
large the stock market overall is never
overpriced over the scope of time there
may be a moment in time that it is or
there may be a moment in time that it's
under priced I'll give you an example
you remember the oil plutt because the
ships were all parked off the shores
because nobody was driving and oil went
down to $0 it's a bear arm sub-zero a
barrel about five weeks ago do you
remember that yeah okay and so that
drove Exxon's stock way down it was
artificially low because it was a
temporary situation so the numbers
didn't justify how low it was other
times something pipes up and the numbers
are artificially high but over the scope
of time they generally correct back and
forth and you know you can look at p/e
ratios profit earnings ratios and you
can look at the book the value of the
company the assets that they own and
compare that to the stock prices and the
outstanding shares and you know most of
the stuff's pretty close so to say that
the Dow is at thirty thousand and it
just cannot maintain why because you
emotionally can't accept it when the
math is actually there that's absurd so
that's like saying you know this piece
of real estate is never worth this well
their rents coming in off of it actually
say it is worth that and so you know I'm
looking at a cap rate on my Noi my net
operating income on this piece of real
estate says it is worth that and so and
seven people right around that have just
paid similar prices for that so yeah it
is probably worth that just cuz you know
when I was a boy that piece of property
sold for you know a hundred times less
does not mean that it's not worth that
today just because I can't emotionally
keep up with the prices there's math on
all of it now again there's there's
examples of individual companies on
stocks or individual pieces of real
estate where they are overpriced or
where they're under priced but buying
law
you have a better chance of sneaking up
on a deal with a piece of real estate
I like real estate I've got a bunch of
it that does that help at all yeah it
does this I mean especially in today's
environment it just the stock market
personally just seems like a giant
casino I mean in some in some instances
why is what why well it's similar to the
two did to the example to ExxonMobil I
haven't checked what their what their
dividend pays but you know the the stock
was was artificially undervalued but if
you know if at the time whenever it was
supposedly correctly valued if I
purchased shares of ExxonMobil I don't
get a portion of their earnings with the
exception of the the amount of dividends
that they pay Hilary
the only way that you are bet you are
betting that Apple McDonald's coca-cola
Home Depot are going to be worth more
five years from now than they are today
and why would you make that bet well you
would look at their track record of
growth the stock price growth and you
would look at the management team and
you look at the profit margins and you
would also kind of project in the future
what you think the business climate is
that they're going to exist in right so
it's not a casino casino is I see no
it's truly a game of chance you have
nothing to analyze there except dice are
going to turn up or cards are going to
turn up right it just seems like the
stock price though isn't tied to that
realistically at all the only way that
it's going to go the stock price is
going to go up in value is if somebody
else wants to buy it for more than I
paid for it well no if the company
continues to grow profits and continues
to grow in size then the stock price
would go up in value
let's take home let's just pick out Home
Depot I don't even know what their stock
does because I don't follow single
stocks I'm just using an example okay
but let's just say with Home Depot let's
say that why would their stock price
grow well let's say they opened another
500 stores and all those stores make a
profit more and they have 500 more
profitable stores than they did have
or coca-cola opens up some new lines
of product and continues to grow so as
long as these companies are diversifying
and growing and adding profits to their
bottom line the stock is going to
continue to be worth more I think you
could probably make the case that Apple
has done a really good job with that
it's almost an iconic stock it's kind of
ridiculous actually but you know and I
don't play single stocks for this reason
but I do buy them as a group in mutual
funds as part of my portfolio and no
it's not a casino it's really not
there's a lot of things you can look at
there that give you a feel for it